[Applause]
can we give some details on this episode
[ __ ]
yeah i don't know the details that's why
i come to you for it okay that's why i
go to mark
mark mark
so far what i understand is this was
the federal judge appointed to an
epstein case and it's between epstein
and deutsche bank is this correct
uh to my understanding is something like
that like it's basically investigating
the money that's wrapped up in
epstein's deutsche bank accounts yes now
because obviously you follow the money
you're going to find the illegal [ __ ]
yeah
i feel at any point in time akash is
going to
dismember me bro akash gave me a look
which was
very simple i just couldn't believe you
put your bare feet on the table son i
realized how dark the bottom was just
from dirt
yeah and i immediately put the
birkenstock back on i got insecure dog i
got insecure they were gonna roast me up
my
and then i was like i'm gonna get
roasted and i saw andrew's burps and i
was like i'm safe
we should be all right nah son i got
great feet i got a great foot how to
focus only on my shoes though y'all say
[ __ ] about his birkenstocks
yo all of us in this room wear birks
let's keep it a buck yeah we're the
bergen boys we're birkin boys
i got a custom pass he got customs i'm
in the game you ever seen them
oh you changed bro i'm looking at the
camera now son
i got the beer trimmed up nice hair's
all done
i did notice you came in with a fresh
cut yo that's how we got mark's shower
and we got alec and crispy
life is good for the flagrant boys yeah
man look at cookie won't even look in
the direction of your [ __ ]
[ __ ] just moved couldn't take it
no more
okay anyway so epstein federal
uh federal judge now an interesting
thing is
that her husband the guy who got killed
was a prosecutor
right was prosecuting this drug dealer
allegedly allegedly all this alleged
right now
allegedly prosecuted his drug dealer and
what happened or he was defending the
drug dealer and the guy got off
i think he was a prosecutor so then he
was going against him
yeah so then he locked the guy up for an
intensive this is something that's not a
red
i don't i don't know if this is
necessarily true but basically someone
suggested that he got
this like drug lord or someone high up
in like a in organized crime
arrested like or put in jail for like 40
years see
and so they're trying to say oh it was
for a 2015 case
and they're saying that the dude
that killed this guy who has
subsequently committed suicide
was doing it because he was angry at
that guy for some reason we're not
exactly sure
he's wrapped up in the gang so they're
like yo this guy put our guy away we
gotta
go take him out how is he wrapped up in
the gang he's like some [ __ ] stiff
i mean like that's what these people
were suggesting are alleging but now
they're also saying the guy is a
men's rights advocate he's like a big
trumper
i didn't see that oh yeah dude this
interesting [ __ ] that's going on about
this is the assassin right
here's my question if you're the
assassin why do you keep signing up to
kill people
no one is not going to end well for you
son mk ultra baby
i don't even know what that means look
so here's the thing we'll get into
a second the suspect whose body was
found in the catskills has been
identified as
lawyer and men's rights activist roy den
hollander it's believed that hollander
had a case pending before
solace where he was challenging the
men's only draft
hollander also once sued chuck todd of
nbc's meet the press
the new york times commentator david
brooks and major garrett of cbs
he accused them of violating the
racketeer influence and corrupt
organizations act by allegedly
committing
wire fraud for publishing fake news
reports about president trump
so that's the report that they're
putting out
so of course the report is
this guy loves trump and he's a men's
rights activist so he's like one of
these disgrunt disgruntled virgins and
he like hates women
and it seems to me it's almost like two
funny thing is last night i think tim
dillon tweeted something like that wait
till they say that
he's an angry man and he's not getting
no [ __ ] and he's a trump or something
it's like almost like as if there's a
book written right you know that is like
this is what you do this is how you
discredit the guy who kills somebody
right after we kill him and then we say
that he could not even discredit just
allow us to compartmentalize it like oh
that's who he is okay
scumbag of course he would do some [ __ ]
like that not this time yo
we might have to get to the bottom of
this one bro this is too crazy dog
what al you don't care i don't in that
crazy knowing cause i thought this was
the
judge that's or the husband of the judge
that's prosecuting
glenn no this is nothing to do with her
no this is epstein
and the bank because so here's where
[ __ ] gets interesting
the bank is where you could tie things
back to people yeah
the the if he's getting the payments
from the clintons
the trumps whoever then you say oh why
is this guy paying you
why are the clintons paying you fifty
thousand dollars what's that about or
why are you paying [ __ ] like
how are you supporting your lifestyle
where's the money
at the end of the day the money needs to
be transferred yeah and deutsche bank
i think i spoke about this on the
podcast but we didn't include it in the
gayland maxwell piece
but the thing about deutsche bank what's
really interesting is that they
went after epstein as a client after he
was a convicted pedophile
so most people the clintons and all them
they sever ties once he gets the
conviction right
so they could always front like oh we
didn't know that was going on right
right a few people continued to have
relationships with him afterwards
for some [ __ ] reason um bill gates
right was like flying on his jet having
[ __ ] dinners with him uptown
wild crazy like you would think even if
that was your homeboy
from a pr perspective you just wouldn't
do it
right you're my homie if you're accused
of
why you keep putting this on me put this
on a legend put that on
that's bloustein and all black
pedophiles
there we go mark kelly marcus who you're
[ __ ]
so you know he's legal yeah that's true
i don't know that we don't know actually
no growing up
it could be a spy
but the point is if anybody i'm close to
is [ __ ] kids i'm not hanging out with
them they just can't that's it i'm sorry
or even if you heard there's a rumor
if there's if you are in trial or if you
are uh on trial for it
yeah that's it bruh we were the only
podcast to come out
and defend chris dalia yeah
how you finishing the sentence we were
the only one no i know
yeah i'm not going to five guys with
them
you know a lot got a lot of time gotta
go on you know what i mean we gotta
figure some [ __ ] out
one month per like accusation i think
boom done
how many accusations no no one month bro
maybe
you going to you going to hang out with
chris delea in [ __ ] october
if he's got dates yeah of course
dates like show dates not dates like 16
year olds oh yeah of course right
no no no that was a legit yeah you know
what i mean yeah
yeah i may have the most patience
yeah you know what i mean anyway look
i'm like yo we don't know
you know what i mean all them girls got
quiet though huh
yeah they were tweeting up the storm and
then they shut that [ __ ] down let me
find out the fedex man came to say
what's up yo
let me find out chris got the hitters
show you a package
real talk let me find out the fedex guy
showed up
oops
look basically it's crazy out here
it's crazy out here in these streets
anybody can get got yeah i'm not gonna
lie i'm a little concerned
i consider getting a body cam double
right
back and forward right what if they come
from
the side it's wide also somebody comes
on the side i'm gonna hit him with that
and also when i'm dead you're gonna find
the truth cause it's gonna be streaming
all the time yes i'm like he did it
that's the blood coming up as i'm trying
to believe breathing
and you're streaming i'm streaming i'm
like they killed me they got me [ __ ]
sorrows coke pepsi
diet dr pepper mr pym is behind it
mr phil is the one but what if you don't
get god then you're just gonna be
streaming the whole time yo imagine
imagine you're one of these conspiracy
theorists and they never try to kill you
like you love [ __ ] losers yo real
talk like
they gotta kill tim they got to kill tim
dillon
or else his life's work will be for
naught
you know what i'm saying like like tim
is out in these [ __ ] and he's
right
every time he's like yo there's a
pedophile ring
and [ __ ] elites are protecting
them and then it comes out there's a
pedophile ring and elise are perfect
protected pedophiles he's like see
i told you he's screaming about it and
the elites are watching his videos like
they're never gonna believe you it don't
matter they gotta kill tim
or they just bring him in just let him
or they bring him in
yeah you think that tim is part of the
he's controlled opposition
i mean he could be if i was if that was
him that's what i would do one
trip rihanni's dinner
[Laughter]
yo you take him to chip right now he
eats way better than that
tim got the best tim got the hands down
best like take you out to dinner [ __ ]
remember that scene in the matrix where
they take the guy out for steak that's
that's tim every time we go out to
dinner that's tim every time every time
he's plugged into the matrix multiple
steaks why is it that we can go to any
restaurant
whenever we oh my god tim
i mean we gotta call tim hold on
no we gotta get to the bottom of this
right now have you seen
tim son tim we gotta get we're calling
him
we're calling him i've i didn't listen
to that
i'll just run
like you can't get packages too you know
they got to come to your door
we got to get to the bottom of this all
right ow do we have that hookup yet or
not we didn't get enough of the things
mark ordered a man late
yo i'm putting that up mark that that's
on mark listen if we don't hear from tim
they could have already gotten to him oh
oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] who was that oh
who was that [ __ ] that's haley who's
that glenn
oh my god guys you heard the british
accent right i heard it
yeah you have reached the tally of
one more chance last chance you
we have tim dillon about to be on the
phone i forgot what i called him about
what was it
making sure he's still alive and he's
not you know tim did he go the other way
hey what's up tim you are currently live
on the flagrant 2 podcast broadcasting
to over half a million people around the
world
okay okay he does not sound happy
now we're just one calling in to make
sure that you're still alive
i'm i'm here yeah okay because you've
been predicting
you've been protected predicting the
behavior
exactly so listen at a certain point of
time
it came to us either two things are true
one
you gotta be furious they haven't tried
to take you out yet
you know they may be trying to take
managers interesting ways like a woman
that ralph's offered me a swiss roll
cake today
so i don't know
i don't know is that insulting that
that's the way they want to kill you as
food
yo tim we're not gonna lose you to food
now
the other thing is this could it be
possible that they found a way to bring
you on to their side
there's no way that you have this i
would do it for i would do it for 200
i mean
you mean they could bring you on like
they could hire you like your roger
stone style you will do whatever needs
to be done for them
yes i mean at a certain point you get to
a point where you're just bored with the
losing side
okay so if you can't beat them join them
is what you're saying
at a certain point you just gotta you
just gotta go hey let's make a little
money
what would it take realistically would
it take land would it take cash
what would it take no they would never
they would never approach me a guy like
me would only be used as a capacity like
they're using this one a guy right now
right there's a guy that they said
killed this judge and then killed
himself
an hour later and supposedly he's a
men's rights activist which i believe he
is but supposedly that he killed two men
yeah he killed two men and then uh fled
an hour and a half away and off himself
um and then but also worked for crawl
associates in russia and also had all
these weird connections i mean it's just
fishy
so they would use me for a guy like that
they did you know
they'd kill someone and then blame it on
me they got tim don't be mad at this uh
you know waitress or whatever i don't
know but that's what they would
i'd be like now tim explain
patsy to people listening that are not
as uh you know
up to date with the conspiracy theory
stuff yeah
it's somebody who you can just say you
can go and do something and then blame
it on somebody
else and you know the most famous
example of that was probably the rv
oswald
apaches are not always innocent
sometimes they actually do the thing
but they were they were like directed to
do it
um but the whole thing is they're
usually like these weird loners
that are into weird creepy politics and
it's believable that they will do
something like this
because they're anti-social
personalities and they're easy
you can turn around and go oh yeah that
guy did it and it makes that
like how brilliant is his present men's
right attack of it how brilliant
uh that he's had a public feud with his
judge
um but again was he harassing her was he
doing anything has he ever been arrested
for anything violent he seems kind of
like a clown
he called up more now maybe if new facts
emerge maybe i'll change my opinion but
as of right now
it looks very shady and i haven't seen
that this guy's had a history of
violence
so we're supposed to believe that he
snapped transferred like a fedex guy
went to go kill this judge ended up just
killing her son and her husband
then fleeing and killing himself in the
middle of nowhere
and then we're all supposed to believe
this because he called opiate because he
called you norton
and complained about women now question
can i throw something out at you you
tell me if this makes any sense
okay um
is it possible that this guy never
killed them
but they used him as somebody who would
likely do it in other words they find
someone
who yes who's got beef with the judge
they isolate him
they kill him and then they frame him
for the murder of the judge's
husband and kid or kid
it's also like this guy's a big fan of
making statements but there's no where's
the manifesto
uh he then just goes and kills himself
in the middle of nowhere and i mean
everybody's like well maybe he just had
some
guilt and then he just killed himself
like yeah okay
sure you know all these things are
statistically possible but like
if you're crazy enough to go kill two
innocent people at their home
you're probably crazy enough to get
arrested for it and tell the world why
you did it
i mean ted kaczynski didn't kill himself
he sat in jail and he writes
manifestos and he really you believe in
something enough to kill somebody
it's very weird that you you you flee an
hour and a half away
and then kill yourself it's very strange
to me that no one can ask him any
questions like maybe he did do this
and through the investigation people
would find out that he was put up to do
it
or that some shadowy figures emerged a
few weeks ago and they were like
yeah dude why don't you kill this
[ __ ] judge i mean
it's amazing that he he will never be
able to be asked any questions
about why he actually did this or what
were the circumstances leading up to it
it's very strange
to me and how does the idea him so
quickly i mean i guess somebody reported
his suicide
this guy shot himself in a car and they
immediately said oh i guess it must be
uh i was
the guy that killed the judge maybe he
was in a fedex uniform i mean i'm trying
to give them the benefit of the doubt
but it's like
it just seems shady yeah it's very shady
and i want you to be careful and protect
yourself and i don't want you accepting
anything from anyone in ralph's in the
very near future
you know the cake looked good so i did
take a minute with it but i didn't go
for it
and uh so i'll be careful but i got tony
hinchcl if you're about to go in the
pool
okay you guys are trying to tell tony i
say what's up love you guys be good all
right i'll talk to you soon
okay so we got to the bottom of it
he's a patsy it's a patsy it's a patsy
you